what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there's a lot happening in the DC
world right now with everybody waiting
to hear from James Gunn about what the
future of the DCU the DC Universe is
going to look like and the great news is
we're going to find out what it looks
like very very soon James Gunn has
already told us that he plans to
announce some of the Slate that he has
planned for the next 8 to 10 years of
the DCU very soon he has even written
what is being called the DC Bible how
everything is going to connect all of
the new things all of the side things
like in Matt Reeves's Batman Universe
and of course some of the old DC
projects that are going to remain now
most of the stuff is going away you can
say goodbye to the old Justice League
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on how you view that but a new Justice
League is coming in a new Superman is
coming in which we do have a little bit
of an update on today as far as casting
is concerned we'll also be talking about
the other universe that includes the
Batman Joker and the other side projects
that are going to be coming out based
off of Gotham and that universe and of
course we'll be talking about the new
DCU slate so if you love GC and you want
to stay up to date be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell now the
first thing we'll talk about because I
know fans are really really excited and
anticipating this is when can we expect
the new DCU slate to be revealed now
keep this in mind I already said it but
I'll say it again James Gunn and Peter
Safran have prepared the next 8 to 10
years of the dcu's future however James
Gunn has specified that when they
revealed the first part of the DCU they
will not be revealing all eight to ten
years we are most likely going to get
probably two to three to four years and
from what we know it is indeed going to
be a reboot but James Gunn has told us
that we can expect to get a big
announcement from him and the people at
DC this month well we're halfway into
the month already which means we have
less than 15 days until we should be
getting this reveal but according to
Grace Randolph on Twitter she has heard
that it could be next week this is what
she said on Twitter I hear there's a
very good chance James gunz's first DC
announcement is next week not sure of
the format tweed's video article in the
trades Etc word is he met with Warner
Brothers Discovery brass all this week
all ready to pitch now whether Grace has
heard something or not is kind of
neither here or there because we really
only have one week left in the month
next week the week after that is only
three days the 29th 30th and 31st so
next week makes sense and we know that
James and Peter are basically done so I
think all that's left now is to
basically meet with Warner Brothers and
figure out how they're going to announce
it and pretty much put it all on paper
and prepare for it now a lot of people
are wondering what kind of movies and
shows that we're going to get and also
games because James Gunn did confirm
that some games are indeed going to be
Canon now since it's a reboot I'm
expecting projects that are going to be
some similar to what we've already
gotten and some that are new like the
Green Lantern James Gunn has already
expressed how important the green lanter
is going to be moving forward he said
that the Green Lantern is an extremely
important character so I wouldn't be
surprised if we get a project around the
Green Lantern however one project that
we should not expect to see in this new
announcement is a Superman Project of
course there's a lot of Buzz around this
right now Henry Cavill came back as
Superman in Black Adam but that was
before James Gunn and Peter saffron came
on board to run DC Studios now they're
on board and now they have said that he
is in fact not coming back and that the
rock is pretty much done as Black Adam
as well at least for now but there was a
rumor going around that Jacob elordi was
going to be James Gunn Superman for the
DCU and in true James Gunn fashion he
took this to Twitter and debunked it but
with his debunk he actually gave us a
pretty decent reveal when asked about
the Jacob elordi rumor he said my
thoughts are are no one has been cast as
Superman yet casting as is almost always
the case with me will happen after the
script is finished or close to finished
and it isn't we'll announce a few things
in not too long but the casting of
Superman won't be one of them and what's
also extremely interesting about this is
that he put an emoji of a mermaid at the
very end leading us to believe that we
might get a new Aquaman announcement
even though Aquaman 2 is going to hit
theaters not too long from now there
will be some complications moving
forward just a little bit because there
is going to be some confusion for people
who don't keep up to date with things
like this every day like we do so for
the Casual fans they know that Jason
Momoa is Aquaman however it does seem
like he's about to play Lobo in the DCU
and if James Gunn really is planning on
introducing a new Superman very soon
possibly next week it could get a little
confusing for some fans because Aquaman
2 is still going to debut this year but
that's just kind of how it goes Henry
Cavill is no longer Superman it also
seems pretty clear that Gal Gadot is no
longer Wonder Woman basically the whole
Justice League that we knew was
essentially gone but what James Gunn
said is pretty interesting we're not
going to get a Superman announcement
with his announcement coming this month
meaning a Superman Project isn't going
to be here probably within the next two
years or so but it does seem like James
Gunn has a pretty good plan so I'm
curious to see what he is going to
announce he did say the reason Henry
Cavill isn't back a Superman is because
his Superman Project is going to focus
on a younger Superman so we can assume
that it's probably going to be the same
for Wonder Woman for the flash or Batman
cyborg Etc so really it's just a reboot
however James Gunn and Peter saffron are
not getting rid of everything it looks
like Matt Reeves is the Batman and its
universe is staying put as we have some
updates on their projects and not just
their universe but also Joker 2 which
we're not really sure how these
universes exist yet we do know that they
exist outside of whatever this new
universe the DCU is going to be Joker 2
with Lady Gaga joining the cast is still
well underway and it has a working title
now his official working title is Juliet
which is perfect because the working
title for the first Joker film was Romeo
so production for Joker 2 falea do is
well underway that's not going anywhere
same thing with the Batman 2 and the
project surrounding it like the penguin
spin-off show they confirmed these are
stained but of course amidst all of the
big changes that are happening fans who
are still kind of unsure however we have
received a great update about the Batman
2. in two separate interviews Matt
Reeves has confirmed the Batman 2 is
happening and they are hard at work in
one interview with comicbook.com he said
I mean I can't give an update on that in
terms of specifics except to tell you
that we are hard at work on the script
my partner and I are deep in it and I'm
excited about what we're going to do
then in another interview with collider
he said I'm not going to answer that
question but we are working on a movie
I'll put it to you that way we're deep
in it and my partner and I Matson Tomlin
and I are writing it it's really
exciting and I'm really excited about
what we're doing he then went on to give
a shout out to Robert Pattinson stating
really excited to be doing that with
Robert Pattinson because I just think
he's such a special person and actor so
great news for the Batman 2. also it's
been revealed that the penguin spin-off
show is going to directly lead up to the
Batman 2 and they'll have a whole
separate Universe from the DCU focused
on Gotham City which is really going to
be awesome to see Matt Reeves's Vision
come to life in regards to the Penguin
series leading up to the Batman 2 he
said there's actually a whole little
fabric of things we're wanting to do the
way we're doing with the Penguin and how
that comes back into how that will lead
into the sequel and what the sequel is
going to be so there's a big Vision
there and the great news is it's not
going anywhere it's going coexist with
James guns as DCU which is great because
I'm excited to see how that separate
Universe turns out I'm also really
excited to see the new Justice League
how they're going to reboot it and the
new actors that are going to come in and
play characters like Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman Etc but let me know what you
think about all of this in the comments
down below are you excited are you
nervous are you afraid let me know
everything don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all DCU news and you can also
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign